[Applause]
okay
it's friday or what cat likes to call
tgi
who threw up in my closet day i wonder
if
she even remembers singing to her cat
last night
[Music]
please
i think we might have a subscribe of him
ah tippy anyway i'm glad janice dean is
back
but you know she is a risk taker
as this video of her can attest
she is healing nicely so here's good
news for citizens of portland oregon
you'll have more time to loot because
the riot squad gave themselves
the boot yeah the guys and gals on the
front lines of mayhem
resigned in mass that's together cat
after the indictment of one of their
officers for allegedly smacking a
photographer during an
overnight riot last august so all 50 of
them
quit can't say i blame them think about
it you're brought in to stop a riot
because that's your job and lately
you've been busier than brian stelter at
the costco free sample cart
there's chaos mayhem smoke fire fists
the stench of body odor it's like the
rehearsal on the set of the view
and all you're trying to do is control
things and save lives and yet you get
busted for hitting someone at a ride who
just happens to have a camera
in the thick of it something alec
baldwin does every day
you see how it's a losing proposition
it's like apologizing to the
woke mob you're damned if you do damned
if you don't
or if you're the remaining law-abiding
citizens of portland who can't move out
just damn to hell
especially when you have a mayor this
pathetically weak
i'm going to do the work that i need to
do here in my local community
with my local officials to take
accountability for what's happening on
our streets
and i'd appreciate that either the
president support us or he stay the hell
out of the way
i stand with you no matter
what and if they launch the tear gas
against you they are launching the tear
gas
against me
how is that appeasement working out fact
is a decorated officer was doing the
best job he could but since our
politicized
criminal justice system has now replaced
an actual justice system
he's the villain he pays not the
criminals it's just the way it goes
in a progressive paradise a little
background on that night in portland
roughly 200 demonstrators had approached
the multnomah building in portland
the media calls them demonstrators but
that's like calling arsonists
careless smokers they came with tactical
helmets armed with weaponry their
cowardly faces covered
exactly what i wore in larry kudlow's
hot tub
[Laughter]
he won't be watching this so they said
fire to dumpsters of course which raises
the eternal question
why the hate against dumpsters maybe
it's self-hatred
garbage attacking garbage or maybe they
think the fire will sterilize the
container before they move in
they defaced buildings broke windows
tossed molotov cocktails
in the multnomah buildings setting it on
fire
in portland this is known as making
s'mores
as in you're going to get s'more rioting
now that you've defunded your police
thank you rioting is more routine in
portland than listening to npr while
charging your prius
so imagine being tasked with dealing
with these
animals i don't even know if i can call
them animals because animals are better
creatures than these sad losers
i mean have you seen the anti-fog mug
shots
be glad they're not scratch and sniff
they look like their fight for justice
includes a war on soap
and clearasil they could be cast in cats
without any makeup i wonder how cnn
portrays antifa
these days aren't they just kind of like
an idea at this point or just peaceful
protesters
yes a brilliant idea they should have
honorary degrees
from every university or better yet a
medal of honor
a nobel peace prize and a stanley cup
sometimes i wish they were
carnival stuffed animals that i could
win and take them home with me
i wish i could take them home with me so
they could get me
pregnant
i don't even think that's as crazy as
cnn normally but what if your job was to
stop these violent cretans but when you
do it doesn't matter
in october of last year county d.a mike
schmidt great third baseman
lawyer rejected over 540 riot related
cases in the interest of justice
resorting to a catch and release policy
for suspects
these are felons not fish that kind of
punishment wouldn't even make jeffrey
tubin put his pants on
this is happening all over thugs get
arrested for terrible crimes
and then release before the next person
they sucker punch hits the ground
a recent monster who sucker punched an
elderly asian woman had been arrested 40
sometimes
if only they'd sent a social worker or a
vegan chef
you'd think maybe the judge would have
seen this coming when cities did away
with bail
but he probably went to an ivy league
school which is like giving yourself a
60 grand a year head injury
so what happens now that the riot cops
aren't going to show up for the weekly
riot
well the rioters rejoice and the
remaining cops have no clue what's going
to happen next there's not enough boots
on the ground
this as massive demonstrations are
planned for the coming weekend
so think about the world's worst mayors
you got the hedgehog homicider
who allowed the greatest safest city to
descend into creepy madness
the upside the thug trying to mug you
has to now step over a dead heroin
addict to attack
you got this deep dish dumbass who
writes psychotic emails
about private time while chicago's
citizens die
being mayor cuts into her me time that's
the crime you got this spineless sacca
jelly who did nothing other than neil
before the arsonist while his city of
minneapolis burned
and you got this putz from portland
would you work for this
asshat sorry calling him an asshat
insults asses and hats
what do all these leaders have in common
other than that they couldn't manage an
arby's never mind a major city
well obviously they're progressive
progressive democrats
seriously don't you think voters would
have learned a lesson by now
that the only thing progressives do is
make things progressively worse
all right here he is let's
welcome tonight's guest
when weather comes to new york it has to
go through her
first fox news senior meteorologist
janice dean
she lets you carry a gun in her
restaurant so you can bet this service
is propped
colorado congresswoman lauren bovers
he made the police look so good they
canceled his show
author of the new book breaking blue
sergeant sean
sticks larkin
she's down to earth especially when
she's passed out on the street
fox news contributor cat tim
all right sean i have to go to you first
you you know you just recently
you're recently retired police
lieutenant when you
this is part of a growing trend that's
happening everywhere and i would say
that the trend actually actually you
know hurt your career
your show i got to say this on the
weekends so this was a mixed bag for me
i enjoyed the show it was beating me in
the ratings
in the demo but then they canceled you
because you were doing
too good of a job making the police
making the police look good they
canceled it making my
show number one in the camera
full circle both circles
that had to have pissed you off uh
dramatically you know and and we were
beating everybody i mean it was the
number one show on friday and saturday
nights typically on cable tv
i was watching it she wasn't even
watching our show
that was on the other one
um but no it did and you know that all
the conversation about policing in
america to me
live pd what it showed was hey this is
really what's going on out here
yeah there was nothing dramatized the
the show the producers nobody picked
what the officers did each night
um they were just in the cars
documenting hey this is law enforcement
in the country
right we showed it in the urban areas we
showed it
in rural areas you name it you saw it
and
uh it's kind of funny being out on the
street still as a police officer when
the show was canceled
even all the bad guys i dealt with were
like where's the show we missed the show
we like watching the show
that's when they get their big break
absolutely yeah that's yeah
we used to have a drinking game when we
would watch live pd
it was like we'd have to drink every
time a suspect was missing a shirt
oh there there was there was live pd
bingo yeah like that
literally you could print off cards
weekly and people played at home and you
know social media was a big part of the
show with twitter live
live live uh tweets and so you got to
see this all night long
the way the viewers interacted with each
other or even with us in studio so
a lot of people miss it and uh fingers
across it'll be back maybe you need
reunion shows where you get the
the cops and the suspects back together
just like real housewives which are
basically criminals
and aren't they criminals janice they're
criminals so what do you make of this
the whole
the whole riot team leaves can you blame
him
i don't and i'm from a family of first
responders my husband
has been a firefighter for 25 years his
brother
is a police detective so uh you know i'm
in a family where people risk their
lives to help others and so to see this
happening
and you know the fire department and the
police department are kind of the same
in that if they
feel like one of their people their
brethren is
is affected they're going to band
together and do something like this so i
i applaud this i feel bad for portland
they're you know
i i don't know how safe it's going to be
there now wow
um but but i mean going back to what was
going on there this is not like
stopping cars for speeding this is like
violence
yeah so what are they supposed to do
just stand there and take it yeah
exactly don't they're supposed to by the
way what does your husband have against
fire
i mean maybe he should look in the
mirror what is fire but really just a
chemical
reaction looking for love would you like
to call him
yes i would and i'm sure it's a
firefighter he wears a red hat
right racist racist exactly a
congresswoman
let's say you were a congresswoman not
in colorado but in portland
what would you do uh well i think the
portland congressman
they just let insurrections happen right
yeah we in seattle we allow chad's we
just you know we just let it
let it happen right it's a peaceful
protest because there it's okay
but you know actually in colorado we've
taken away qualified immunity from our
police officers
and it's devastating and now they want
to do it on a national level in congress
the house passed it
and you know now we're the few
republicans who stood up to say you know
we're not going to pass this uh this
this legislation for the gold medal for
the capitol hill police because they
just
they just want to use them for their
political games
and we've already passed it once they
come by they rewrite
it they add another officer and has
nothing to do with january 6th
and then we have officers going to
members offices
congressional offices saying why did you
vote no
on the gold medal bill well i hope those
same officers are going to all the
democrats that represent portland
and seattle and all these other crazy
cities and and saying
why did you vote to defund us why did
you vote to take away our qualified
immunity
and make us personally responsible for
our jobs i mean these guys
they love their communities and i'm
proud of the stand that they took there
in portland uh because enough is enough
and
uh i think we're gonna see this uh
happening a whole lot more
yeah uh cat when you look at portland do
you think it's a lost cause because i
can't figure out how you go back
like if you if you equate any kind of uh
law and order or disciplinary action
as a aggression or an affront
there is no answer at that point other
than the
the quick roll to just chaos right well
much like your hair tonight thank you
hey i would i would take some fox news
hair i didn't have it i
and i've been there when she's taken
pieces out oh yeah i'll do it in public
i have no shame but i don't do arson
no you don't and the reason why arson
is generally not an effective strategy
is because it's not allowed
so if you do the arson there's people
who stop the arson and you get in
trouble
but if you are allowed to do arson
it's incredibly effective yeah that's
true it's incredibly effective because
yet now all these people quit which is
what they want and i'm somebody who does
want police reform i disagree with you i
think we should end qualified immunity
however i don't think that we should
have no police which is what these
people want
right they want no police they want no
prisons and because they're allowed to
do
unbridled arson people are quitting and
they're getting what they want
it's hard to be this stupid but they're
pulling it off yes
all right hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else